are you ready to podcast that's not
wrong intro hey guys welcome to Gavin
the game podcast today we're talking
about imposter syndrome we're also going
to be doing some life updates and that's
it we have a very interesting thing of
the week also so um first off we can
touch on some what's news yeah yeah we
just pass 700,000 subscribers on our
main YouTube channel it's very exciting
which is super exciting yeah I changed
the little we have a little sign like a
little marquee little light-up sign in
our living room I changed it this
morning just say 700 K instead of 690 K
we changed it every 10 K and we do a
little like happy dance so thank you all
for your support over on our main
channel also we've been able to grow the
gaming channel like the gaming channels
growing really great just time to
celebrate loss of things we have five
gaming editors now podcast that is
that's kind of crazy to me that that has
grown so much and sometimes we even
released three videos per week over at
the gaming channel which is something
that I never really would consider us
doing and if you think about it Kaitlyn
some days we release five videos per
week podcasts yeah some weeks yet we do
a podcast three gaming videos and the
main channel video and also all the
uncut so sometimes we're releasing like
eight videos in a week which is
ridiculous yeah and because the podcast
is only every other week and right now
the main channel is only every other
week sometimes sometimes it might be
only six videos we have sometimes like
like three edited ones and three other
uncut ones but it's uh it's it's really
interesting adding all of that to our
life I know there's a kind of an
unplanned side tangent that we're having
right now but um it's it's uh we've
gotten some questions about like why
we're doing gaming instead of like more
main channel videos and it's really just
because that's we have
fun with and we really want to like stay
ahead of burnout and it's just uh and we
don't have fun with the main channel
videos yeah yeah obviously have a lot of
fun with those too but it's like each
one of those takes so much extra work
and add so much extra stress as well
because that's like where all of our
commitments are whereas the gaming is
very flexible and because we do things
like hire out the editing and it only it
only takes us a few hours you know to
make the content picots edited or gets
put up so it's a great input vers output
ratio for us yeah we have fun with both
but I think the difference is with the
main channel there's also stress and
with the gaming channel there's not
really any stress and so it's it's been
really fun for us to be able to do a
little bit more gaming than we used to
do in the past and it means like we're
not you know making as much because
we're not doing as many main channel
videos we're not you know so our income
has gone down some short-term
financially it makes no sense growth on
the main channel is slowed a little bit
because we're not you know we're not
posting as much so you don't have as
many videos going out there but it it
makes us really happy and we we have
been feeling a lot less stress than we
did last year or the year before that or
the year before that so it feels like
we're on a good path and I mean this is
again I'm just going deeper down the
side tangent but last night we were
talking about how like it seems like
there's two very challenging periods of
like life as someone putting stuff on
YouTube one is that the very initial
period where you're trying to get your
feet under you and trying to get that
like initial little boost of growth you
know it's so hard but the other really
hard period is just not burning out and
we're trying to we've constantly been
trying to like preemptively prevent that
we've had periods where we have
recognized that if we keep this up we
will sober now like we understand so
completely how it's possible and
a lot of people get there because also
we are in a very lucky position we
realize that and with that lucky
position comes so many great
opportunities and it's hard and weird to
turn down good opportunities when other
people don't have those opportunities I
don't we all I almost feel guilty
yeah like turning some of these down for
the sake of our own health it's like
well I should just do everything because
I'm lucky and in this position to just
do more and more and more but then you
can so lose it and then just crash and
burn mm-hmm so dancing yeah that's all
part of the reason why we've slowed down
the main channel a little bit yes
but going back to our main topic and
going a little bit back into the past we
wanted to talk a little bit about
impostor syndrome and specifically maybe
Caitlyn can touch on some of her
concerns there but I think one of the
reasons while we haven't talked about it
up until now is because now I feel like
and Caitlyn cried for you from wrong but
it had a much better place yeah we don't
want it like this would be the evident
Caitlyn complain podcast I mean what we
kind of want to wait until things are
the better place then we can tell
stories of when things weren't as good
but and now how they're bedded now it's
like a complete story with the conflict
and resolution instead of just saying
things are tough yeah yeah that's two a
night well I think impostor syndrome is
something like that a lot of people can
relate to no matter what you do you know
like it could be you're at a position at
work and you're like do other people
know that I don't know what I'm doing
because I don't know and so I think it's
like a very relatable thing even though
we have a job that's like not a typical
job yeah yeah okay so it's probably
texting me people is my phone buzzing so
it I think this is something that
affected me more than it affected you
back in the day at least the specific
reason that I felt imposter yeah the
specific reason
so why weren't you touch on that so so I
used to and I still maybe do a little I
still do some but it was worse in the
beginning but when we first started our
channel I felt a lot of imposter
syndrome um like as a maker because I
felt like more than most people I didn't
really know what I was doing like I was
I was pretty skilled and like you know
advanced crafting and I was decent at
kind of like home improvement type stuff
like things like patching drywall and
painting a room and you know things like
that where it's it's uh not doesn't
requires like fine skill but when we
started our maker channel and we were
doing woodworking and using power tools
and stuff like that
I was pretty much brand new to that when
we started our channel well I think one
thing that that's interesting to touch
on because what we're making our videos
and I think that in terms of how you
thought about our business and
everything you never felt like things
were uneven there or imposters imposter
syndrome in terms of like creating
content right because you were the major
part of that I mean you were more than
50% of us making content because we were
both on screen but then you were doing
all the editing yeah but that didn't
really like factor into my imposter
syndrome because like the audience
doesn't know who's editing could be
neither of us for as far as I know they
don't know like you know unless you
explicitly say it people don't know how
long that takes or how much time that is
and it's um it's still different and I I
didn't like the imposter syndrome I
thought it wasn't about like oh I don't
feel like an equal part of this channel
it was more like I feel like I'm
portraying myself as knowing what I'm
doing more than I actually do oh we
touched on I think we can do a whole
episode on collaborations about like I
think that the thing that stressed
Kaitlyn out the most is that like if we
were in a collaboration
and she was asked to do something that
she wasn't comfortable with she didn't
feel as comfortable as I felt saying I
don't know how to do that yeah which is
weird cuz I should have felt totally
comfortable saying I don't know how to
do that I think it was more like I felt
like there would be so many more things
that I would not know how to do then you
so like you know if let's say we're
doing a collab um
which is the reason it I like thought
about it a lot in collabs is because
you're in a situation out of your
control like if Evan and I were filming
something and I was like you know how
come how come every time I drill it it's
crooked like I can't get a good sight on
it like how come how do I drill straight
or you know whatever the thing is I
could ask him a super basic question
he'd give me some tips we'll pause the
camera he could give me some tips I
could do some practice once and then I
could do it on the real thing and that's
how I was learning like I was literally
learning on the job I had not really
used a drill like I mean maybe I've done
some like sloppy drilling you know mhm
but like nothing in like a fine
woodworking piece because like when in
terms of our woodworking experience we
were equal equally zero pretty much I
mean we had done the love letters and we
had done a little bit but I mean like at
my jobs I had used tools but in terms of
woodworking I hadn't but I feel like
they're still like like in use of tools
there are things that carry over between
- yeah like how the whole thing yeah
it's just like with them with video
games if you're an experienced gamer and
if you have an experienced game right
and not experienced gamer and you put
them down in front of a brand new game
the experienced gamer is gonna
intuitively know like oh that on the
bottom left that's that's probably my
health okay I need to keep an eye on and
you press all the buttons and
intuitively figure it out you're gonna
know that like oh the right joystick is
probably what changes camera angle
you've no one told you that or and yeah
how many like learn the timings of how
in the Dodge where I was like someone
who has never done it it might be harder
because like you're kind of like
retuning the the skills you already know
to a different circumstance as opposed
to learning the skills fresh yeah so
there's like a little bit of that yeah
the reason like with co.labs it was so
much more stressful as we were cold like
you know doing a collab with someone who
was always in every case a skilled maker
who like you know did their thing and I
felt like I you know when we were doing
videos I would lean heavily on Evan for
like the actual physically like making
of things and in a collaboration I can't
just be like hey Evan uh person wants me
to use this I've never done that how do
I do it can we pause and can everyone
wait for me to learn you know so it
would that was a big stress I think
that's one reason why I stressed more
about co.labs a side note about collapse
everyone we've done collapse would have
been an amazing teachers oh my gosh no
like we learned so much and it's all
been really good like I would never
expect I be like using a dang power
hammer that could smash me yeah you know
and like I mean we don't we don't wanna
list every single person but even on the
woodworking aside and we were the Johnny
Brooks oh my god both of us learned so
much about like routers and yes like all
like a bajillion thing and position were
like I didn't know something and like
the person we were collaborating like
Johnny it was like teach me how to do
like the like plunge router and so yeah
it was awesome learned some really
really cool things like my fear was kind
of it was in my head I had okay I had a
little bit of you're working with the
power hammer I wasn't worried I was
gonna go up to it and I was gonna slam
down and the metal was gonna go flying
everywhere I I think that a little bit
of like one reason why we might have a
little bit of a difference here some of
it I think some part part of it is the
things that you've touched on already
how I might have had a little bit more
experience with tools in general from my
engineering jobs
and the prototyping I did there but I
think another part of it is a little bit
of personality yeah I kind of dislike go
into things jump into things don't
overthink thing there's a lot things
will probably work out I mean I I just
have this unwarranted confidence and a
lot of things that I do yeah and Caitlin
likes I don't have that to know that
things are gonna turn out okay and she
likes to have the whole thing planned
and she likes to you know Caitlin was a
straight-a student
yes and I would just like turnout I
think another thing cuz he and I feel
like a lot of it is when it when it
comes to making stuff like the parts
that I that I would feel impostor
syndrome before a big one was just like
using tools another one was with the
design because you also did all the 3d
modeling and I could help sketch
something and I feel like I I do help
with like the aesthetics of like in the
design but like with with the tools I
think another part of of that is that
you have like a very you have an
inherent interest in tools and gadgets
and gizmos and like toys I like a thing
to work and I appreciate features that
benefit me but I don't get as like
excited about it you're not as much of a
tool gremlin I'm not and so like I think
you would naturally like do more
research and play with it more and learn
it and I would just be more like okay
I'll just use it to do the thing oh that
one was good or oh that one was bad you
know like oh I like that so I don't like
that tool but I wouldn't I wouldn't
spend as much time like learning it or
doing research or comparing and so like
it was just kind of like Oh hand me
whatever drill you decided we need yeah
yeah you know I think there's two things
that have really helped mm-hmm one I
think we can talk about you can
how we have shifted focus of our videos
because that's something that you really
helped guide us which with which I think
was really good yeah in terms of like
DIY to watch us do this and learn with
us well they're both they're both yell
both you mean like instructional first
entertainment instructional versus
entertainment yeah but I think there's
still a learning value in watching our
videos in a way but it's not as much I
think that in our beginning videos we
just the way that most people in our
space did it is they did instructions
they're like do this do this do this do
this use this don't use that or whatever
that's what we did and I think that that
made you uncomfortable because you were
saying words that you didn't truly
believe yeah I'm saying words without
the confidence of knowing like is this
truly the best way to do that or like
Evans the one that figured that out but
because we're trying to balance who's
doing the voice over and who's using the
tools 50/50 on screen I'm the one saying
it and demonstrating it but it was like
Evan just spent 20 minutes figuring it
out why edited some clips yeah that
often like because when we started this
it was such a like 10:00 p.m. till 1:00
a.m. type operation oftentimes you know
would be after work it'd be after all of
our other responsibilities were done and
we are fitting it into this really tiny
parts and Caitlin is the person that
edits our videos really well and that's
what makes like more than almost
anything I think the Edit is the most
important part of our videos that and
the idea because so much is crafted
didn't edit but because I wanted to give
Caitlin all of the time possible to edit
and remove stress from her plate I would
do a lot of the pre research I do a lot
of prepping priming and stuff and I'd
bring Caitlin up to speed and I think
one thing that really gave me some
insight into how you felt is when we did
the first Wonder Woman cosplay do you
remember that yes I did because we
first we reversals somewhat yeah I
remember I was doing something
high-priority you were working you're
probably like prepping for the next
project or something something where my
that might have been when I was
freelancing and I had a lot of freelance
work yeah but when we did the the Wonder
Woman cosplay which I never finished but
the headband and the bracers that was
one that like I was super excited about
so instead of what we normally do which
was like Evan would kind of do the
research figure out what we need I was
doing that and then I would like
communicate to him what we needed and
that kind of give it gave us a sense of
like I was able to feel the frustrations
he might feel of like feeling like like
I'm having to instruct every every like
part of it and you were feeling the
frustrations I might feel of like coming
in and feeling a little bit lost you
know yeah I think that that um we got a
lot better with like we got so much we
got so much better at communicating
after that I mean I think that that some
people like view our relationship we've
seen like you guys must have fights this
isn't like your personality this really
is us I mean you can watch like an eight
hour stream of us playing Minecraft you
know it's like sometimes when we do our
live streams we come in with high energy
but after eight hours there's like no
veneer or polish on us anymore yeah like
that's how we are but I mean they're
having moments where we have in stressed
and where this this job that we love has
caused us stress and honestly the the
most stress this job has ever caused us
is in the first year year and a half of
making videos at the very beginning of
the video
prepping it getting it on the same page
like figuring out the messaging all of
that those were some stressful times
because we never had enough time we were
always just rushing so there's time
pressure there's communication pressure
there's like us both trying to get on
the same page and everything and it was
it was stressful for a while I really
know where I was going okay
imposter syndrome so I think like Evan
was mentioning I was one of the big
factors and pushing to change our
content and I think a big reason for
that was because of the imposter
syndrome I felt like I just felt like
what we were putting out there like it
wasn't a true representation of who I
was you know which sounds kind of like I
don't know cheesy but I just felt like
not fully honest because like what we
were doing was these very concise and
controlled tutorials that didn't really
show like we would we would still like
include some mistakes here and there but
I just felt like I was presenting myself
as like way more skilled than I actually
was and so we gradually does one of the
many many reasons that we gradually
started changing it from like a step by
step thing to a like hey we're gonna try
this thing and we may not know what
we're doing fully and were just gonna
figure it out and when we started
presenting things like that I got way
more comfortable just kind of like
admitting that I don't know how to do
stuff or saying like like Evan can you
help me with this like there's also a
few incidents like we actually took down
a video private at a video where we use
to push sticks wrong because we are
making an instructional video and we
showed something wrong and we didn't
want someone to copy us yeah that like
you know making an instructional like
Caitlin brought it up but I was a
hundred percent on board and we we found
a shared vision with where to go and
we've been pursuing that shared vision
but there's like Caitlin said there's a
bajillion reasons why but also when
you're making an instructional video you
you really want to get things right and
like there's a perception and I've heard
like a lot of other makers talk about
this there's a perception that if you
are doing an instructional video and
you're putting it on the internet
especially if you have a you know
decent-sized audience there's a
perception that you have some sort of
authority on the matter and you're like
no what you're saying and even though I
do think there are some things that we
can like we do have knowledge in and we
we
like could do instructional videos on
pretty confidently I still don't want to
do this but also it's like there's only
so much that you can have a mastery of
yeah we just wanted to be Jack's of all
trades instead of masters of nine cuz ya
get bored easily and we like to mix it
up yeah but but also oh wait Jack's of
all trades masters of none yeah I think
that yeah you hit the nail in the head
with that but also it's like if we were
gonna make instructional videos on all
these things would have to like learn it
and then teach it which was missing like
like so inefficient for our time and we
ought we knew that time was always going
to be limited so we like sharing the
learning sharing in the growth and also
I think that it's almost more of a
powerful message saying we don't know
exactly what we're doing we're gonna
figure it out as we go we'll make
mistakes and we'll get to someplace
pretty good most of the time yeah I like
that message more than look at us we are
experts yeah and that is a good message
for some people who are experts and
saying hey we're experts let me show you
my expertise and demonstrate it and
that's really cool but that's not us
yeah yeah that's not really our style
but I do think making that change was
one of the biggest factors that like
relieved my imposter syndrome because I
do feel like someone that you know has
some skills but definitely doesn't know
everything and I feel like I can like
there's room in our video editing style
to show that and like be honest about it
rather than like back when we were doing
three to five minute videos that were
just very concise steps there's no room
for that added like nuance and so I felt
like I like wasn't being truly
representative of the nuance situation
yeah and when I watch our old videos
they were so short so short
they're sorry yeah we only had like one
song they're super short and they saw
some fun personality I still like them I
saw like I'm proud of how they turned
out I felt like 30 songs in one video
I'm not even joking like 20 to 30 songs
per video but yeah I think I think that
was a pretty big factor I think another
thing is like now that we have these
other outlets like the podcast and
streaming and you know we just have more
ways to talk with you guys you know we
have like patreon now all these things
that we didn't have in the very
beginning I think like we've been able
to communicate more and kind of share
our actual real experiences and share
like from business side of things like
what we do like we've talked about how
like because we're trying to be
efficient sometimes we'll film a little
bit where we eat sand a little bit and
then I'll say cool I'm gonna go edit and
I've been finished as the sand anger and
that's something that like I would have
felt was being misleading before I would
have been like oh man I I feel really
bad that like we're each getting equal
time on the video showing us sanding but
like it's 90% oven and now because we
have these other ways to like talk to
you guys about that behind the scenes
stuff I don't feel like it's being
misleading anymore
yeah you know one thing that's
interesting kind of side pivoting
towards imposter syndrome in another
circumstance when we gave our first talk
oh man I felt nervous but I didn't
actually feel an imposter syndrome
because we are talking about something
that we did really have some expertise
in our very first talk was how to start
grow and monetize a YouTube channel
right yeah I think we we were able to
tailor it to something that worked with
us being a new channel because we were a
pretty new channel we were a year old
somewhere around there we were like
forty thousand subs thirty thousand subs
yeah so still a pretty new channel
giving a talk
at a conference but yeah because we
tailored it to work with that and be
true to that I didn't I was nervous but
not in a imposter syndrome kind of way
yeah that's interesting but it is kind
of it's like changing our content to
match the truth well we are yeah are in
their truth being goofus is like I don't
know I see some parallels between them
yeah there is there's definitely a
difference between imposter syndrome and
being nervous yeah I mean I know that
that seems like a fairly obvious
statement to say but imposter syndrome
is very it's like very specific imposter
syndrome is mainly like is it about
feeling like you're misrepresenting
yourself it's kind of like feeling like
people view you in a way that is like
maybe greater than you would view
yourself like people see you as being
like more awesome than you think you are
or something you know just to put it in
simple terms or more skilled or more
having more authority or whatever the
thing is yeah feeling like how people
view you isn't matching up with how you
view it
yeah that makes sense I like you
probably felt it a little bit just doing
just you know being an authority or like
not being an authority but like
presenting things in a like here's how
to do this project when we had like
maybe just figured out we didn't really
know if it was the best way or not
honestly no honestly the the thinking
back a little bit on my life and maybe
if I thought even more I practice out
more before the podcast but thinking
back on my life some the the time I felt
most like an imposter in a way is
actually at my old job as an engineer
doing engineering things
like I had always thought I was gonna do
like it always planned you'd think that
I just fit right in and I wouldn't have
any problems with that but because I
wasn't in control of what I was working
on what I was presenting on and stuff
like that I was pushed into situations
that I wasn't fully comfortable with
like developing a product too fast
perhaps or presenting on something that
wasn't fully finished or what-have-you
just because of the the pressures of
business because of all these various
business t like reasons I mean you know
the typical the typical business reason
stuff I felt like I was misrepresenting
myself or my work or the truth of the
situation and I think that's where I
actually felt the most imposter syndrome
might be a strange word but yeah like
like a little bit like I was lying about
the situation in a way yeah and I think
that kind of fits imposter syndrome yeah
a little bit I definitely like gone into
meetings right definitely didn't feel
the most confidence in what I was saying
yeah I remember when I first started
freelancing it's like when you when you
start doing graphic design a very
important thing is having a portfolio of
your work and if you haven't done if you
haven't had any clients you don't have a
portfolio so it's like you kind of have
to just do mock-ups of examples of
things you could do and I remember like
showing off some of my mock-ups I'm like
this was just something I don't like
start showing some examples somewhere
and then you gradually replace that with
like yeah this away you were never like
really falsely representing those not
really yeah like a design I did yeah but
it was like here's an example of some
like types of fliers I could design you
know what I mean or whatever this is
another strange question yeah imposter
syndrome
we are youtubers
when we have been hanging out with other
large youtubers did he ever feel an
imposter syndrome there like I think the
very first time the biggest imbalance
and subscribers we ever experienced was
when we were hanging out with red Bangor
there were like 4 million subs and we
were at like 40 something like that I'm
not sure how we told that story we
haven't told that story almost anywhere
no yeah we posted a picture a really
long time ago oh yeah we hung out with
Robin Curran and Johnny Brook craft a
workshop we were doing a collab with him
and he knew them and so we all hung out
one night I I didn't really feel like
imposter syndrome though because like we
were just we were just hanging out
hanging out we just like went out to a
bar and hung out and there was no like
it wasn't like we were you know what I
felt more imposter syndrome huh like at
being at an event with other youtubers
actually was um we went to this one
called staffed ax in Austin yeah April
Wilkerson invited us and you know we're
walking around talking to different
companies trying to like you know pitch
our brand try to get their sponsor and
it was the type of event were like they
there was like four youtubers at the
whole event thought you know five six
whatever it was not like a YouTube heavy
event and so the people we were pitching
it to were very much like April would go
up and do these pitches and she was so
confident she had her numbers ready she
was like she's impressive numbers yeah
she was like this is what I can offer
you and this is what you're gonna get in
return this is what I expect you know
and I'd love to work with you and I was
like dang she is so good at like
pitching her channel and like doing
business stuff and like I feel like we
learned a lot on that trip and we we got
to her like like we work very
comfortable talking with ya but he used
but like in that moment I was like man
I'm compared to her I feel very
underprepared don't like pitch her
channel to sponsors we were a lot
smaller also so really a lot of imposter
syndrome is when you
pair yourself to others yeah or if you
feel like you're falsely representing
something yeah yeah there's like two
causes yeah
comparison and lies yeah but yeah I
think that uh
I'm glad we're talking about it now and
and I'm glad that things are a lot
better as I'm thinking I'm glad the
things had a much better place because
where we're at now and what the videos
we're making right now I feel so like
right about them I feel so natural about
like things mm-hmm yeah no I I do too I
feel like things like our you know an
accurate representation of us and what
we do like even with the last video the
mini arcade charger it was like we very
clearly like I kind of took on the like
design and the painting you took on like
the 3d printing 3d modeling and like I
didn't feel like we needed to like
balance things like purposely or try to
like oh well it looks like I'm not doing
enough maybe I should take on some extra
sanding it was like no it's fine like
you know these are the things that were
that we did and this it's just how the
video is and how it was made and like I
don't I just don't really like to think
about it so much now yeah um we're isn't
in the past like it was just something I
was a lot more conscious of but now that
our videos are filmed much more just
like real time you're hanging out with
us as we go not so much pre-planned
shots because it used to be a lot of
pre-planned shots um it just it's just
something I don't really think about too
much anymore which is good and I think
like I'm sure that so many other people
out there you know doing similar things
to what we do or just in life in general
feel impostor syndrome like it's not
something unique to us yeah and I I do
think there's like comfort and that it's
kind of like you know when you become an
adult and you're like wow I'm an adult
now I don't I don't know what I'm doing
and then you
well none of the other adults know what
they're doing - okay that makes me feel
a little bit better it's kind of like
that I totally agree with that while
you're in the middle of that sentence I
thought of something like really very
interesting that I want to talk about no
but like do you have anything more about
the term artist Oh
oh gosh okay I was I was thinking about
other times I might have felt imposter
syndrome as an artist oh yeah yeah you
know it's like you know doing doing our
YouTube videos making the stuff I do
feel confident with that but defining
myself as an artist I feel weird about
it I have done art I like doing art but
the term artist is very loaded and yeah
strange and there's a lot of like
feeling this around that I think for all
artists and like what art is and like
because I think it's so subjective it's
silly I'm sure you can be like okay you
you put multiple pieces of wood together
and made a new thing you're a woodworker
yes
but it's like you could swing some black
paint across a white canvas and be like
I'm an artist or you can do like a Bob
Ross style landscape and say I'm an
artist or you can like sculpt something
out of your accent say I'm an artist but
like there's so many different ways to
define what it's like what if like
someone like accurately recreates
a photo using paint you know it's like
that's obviously an artist but like
everyone has a a different feeling for
what an artist is and I feel like a lot
of artists have lots of reservations
about labeling themselves artists and I
think it is a lot because of the
imposter syndrome and that's something
that both of us have kind of dealt with
I know personally and when I go on
deviantART I just sometimes get
depressed
yeah but for cotton contacts both of us
did art in high school and college like
Evan painted a lot I drew mostly I
didn't really start painting told me
artist is still part of my identity and
I do identify as an artist but I do
still have mixed feelings about it the
call saying like the word artist doesn't
have any like negative connotations to
me but saying it about myself is just
proof that I feel impostor syndrome
about it because like I save your site
or do art you're so much more of an
artist than I am yeah but like oh that
word just makes me uncomfortable used to
refer to to myself and because it's like
I don't know it's like I do some art
sometimes yeah I think because artist is
a noun with a lot of like a noun and an
adjective with a lot of mm mixed thing
is going on for it you know I mean
because an artist is just a person that
has art but also an artist can be
someone where that's their profession
you know with an engineer it's like yes
there's a more freer life or but also
someone who's very skilled at a specific
thing could be described as an artist
and so the word artist also has this
like overlap with like being very
professional in some ways it's like
someone who oh man I wish I could
remember the name of his channel but
that guy that does little jewelry videos
oh yeah it's jewelry and well yeah it's
just so good it's a it is art but it is
also like a very skilled craft and
you're like that man is an artist yeah
you know but there's like a certain
level of prestige associated with the
name it's not just a person who does art
it's almost like there should be like
artists should be two different words
like the casual like casual artist and
then like professional artists our teeth
are teeth whose artists and that our
teeth yeah yeah I think that's maybe
maybe the reason why why there's so much
mixed emotion about it because artists
can mean this thing was way up here and
you feel like you're here even though
you're an artist too
it's like the same word is being used
for two different things and they are
different but interestingly you could
apply that to making - you could be like
I'm a maker and like maybe your skills
up here but maybe your skills down here
but you feel like you can't say you're a
maker because you're not I think that
it's at a different level though because
maker is still like this nitty gritty
like community that's come together
around making which is awesome you can
say that because you didn't feel
impostor syndrome about it but I did but
I think that there's the the maker
community is a little bit more welcoming
and smaller and more more a little more
I will say that but there is still a
little bit of a stigma in the maker
community about being too crafty being
to like DIY like anyone in the maker
community and we kind of laugh about it
- is gonna look at something like a lot
of like five-minute craft stuff and of
course a lot of its cuz it's just dumb
yeah but it's also that you know there's
just like a little bit of a stigma
against things that are crafty as not
that they are bad but like they're not
making yeah but also I think that
there's another aspect of it is the word
artist worldwide everyone knows what an
artist is is a newer term I think that
some of the same things apply and you
can't argue with me because I'm doing
that feeling that's about what I feel in
my heart and you can't tell me I feel
something that I don't feel I'm not
arguing I'm not arguing
you are correct within your own heart
thank you
I validate you Gaylord you're validated
thank you know now that I've been
validated should we move on to anything
of the week yes move on the very week
and now I've been playing with it the
whole time oh yeah we got pause for the
music oh yeah
okay music music played so the thing of
the week is someone something that
someone made for us and got in the mail
and I'm treating very respectfully yes
great painstakingly made so our thing of
the week should it be the thing or the
video both the video being in a video
and it is so we had someone a fellow
youtuber and fellow maker and artists
fellow maker and artist who um we've
seen his comments pop up on our videos
for a long time so when he reached out I
recognized his user name but um the guy
that reached out his name is Tyler in
his channel that he runs with his
brother Connor is called the random bros
and they have all sorts of types of
videos on their channel it truly is
random stuff but they made us tight
Tyler made us these little it's so cute
these enk Evan and Catelynn themed chess
pieces and chess board they're all 3d
printed like everything is meaningful it
has meeting so there's like there's a
googly eye piece there's a geode piece
there's tool pieces my favorite is the
little jube which has like tan thread
wrapped around it to look like
scratching post
yeah is that there is that threat i I'm
I'm so I don't know how to play chess so
I'm gonna have to teach me in honor
I thought the rook was young yeah Rosie
oh yeah you're right there's a Minecraft
block
yeah the castle is in Minecraft Balkan
on one side and a Z on one side is K the
king is an E screwdriver the queen is a
K on a saw on a saw the pond is a googly
eye yeah um do we go through every that
we're so cool oh they're so cute and
there's a really really cute video that
they put together mm-hmm
we appreciate it yeah yeah we really
appreciate it the video is really funny
um Tyler's in high school and made these
and like I'm just super impressed by the
creativity that went into them so we'll
put a link to their video it's really
funny it's a you know short little quick
video you should definitely go check it
out
again channel is with the random bros
and we'll have a link Thank You Tyler
yeah um and I think that that wraps it
up I think all right guys thank you so
much for watching and and/or listening
we appreciate you guys sending your time
with us we hope you're having a
wonderful day and look forward to seeing
you in the next podcast
[Music]